وفي ابرز التطورات الميدانيه اعلنت هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه تصدي قواتها لاكثر من
مئه هجوم روسي خلال يوم واحد على جبهات
بخموت وليمان ومارينكا وشاختار شرقيه
اوكرانيا واكلت هيئه الاركان المواصله
القوات الروسيه محاولات التقدم نحو مقاطعه
دونيس
مشيره الى ان القوات الروسيه شنت اربع
وثلاثين ضربه جويه يوم امس كما شهدت اكثر
من 60 بلده في دنيا
البلاد قصفا صاروخيا ومدفعيا روسيا وفقا
للبيان
وبدورها قالت القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه ان
الدفاعاتها اسقطت احدى عشره طائره مسيره
من طراز شاهد من بين 16 طائره اطلقت
باتجاه الاراضي الاوكرانيه وفي مقاطعه
ذاتروجيا قالت اداره العسكريه ان القوات
الروسيه استهدفت المدينه بصواريخ من طراز
اس 300 ما الحق اضرارا باحد المجمعات
السكنيه ومن جانبها اعلنت الاداره
العسكريه في دنيفرو بتروبيسك ان طائرتين
منشاه وصفتها بالحساسه في نوفو موسكو شمال
شرق المقاطعه
ومن جانبها نشرت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
مقطع فيديو قالت انه لهجوم نفذته طائره
مسيرا انتحاري روسيا من نوع
هذه الطائره منظومه صاروخ تابعه للجيش
الاوكراني متمركز في احد الحقول في محور
اذيافكا كما يبين المقطع تفجير الذي حصل
في المنظومه الصارفيه التي نفذتها المسيره